[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna paradies einen guten abend
wünsche ich ihnen was im sport passiert
ist das erfahren sie von norbert lehmann
guten abend und hierauf schauen wir
ausführlich in den nächsten 20 minuten
brutaler krieg von oben weil die
russischen truppen am boden kaum
vorwärts kommen greifen sie immer mehr
städte aus der luft
am limit wegen omikron krankenhäuser
haben es gerade doppelt schwer weil zu
viele mitarbeitende ausfallen und
gleichzeitig zu viele patienten ein bett
brauchen
so schnell kann's gehen vor gut zwei
jahren noch ein planungs projekt hat die
tesla fabrik in brandenburg heute die
ersten elektro autos ausgeliefert
die ukrainische regierung geht davon aus
dass die kämpfe mit russland innerhalb
von zwei bis drei wochen enden könnten
so der berater des präsidenten selensky
noch aber gibt es heftige gefechte
und so erklärte un-generalsekretär gut
er es heute selbst wenn mario pohl fällt
kann die ukraine nicht stadt für stadt
straße für straße haus für haus erobert
werden der krieg sei nicht zu gewinnen
antoine kurschilgen und volker check
über die kennzahl
angriff aus der luft in mariupol hier
werden industrieanlagen bombardiert sagt
die ukrainische armee
am boden rücken die truppen weiter vor
offenbar sind auch tschetschenische
kämpfer an der schlacht um mario pohl
beteiligt wie diese bilder zeigen sollen
nach ukrainischen angaben befinden sich
noch mehr als 100.000 zivilisten in der
stadt die raus wollen aber nicht können
der ukrainische präsident sprach heute
per videoschalte vor dem italienischen
parlament auch über die lage in der
schwer umkämpften hafenstadt
ukrainische städte werden zerstört
einige städte sind komplett zerstört wie
mario pohl am asowschen meer wo etwa
eine halbe million menschen lebten wie
ihre stadt genua wo ich gewesen bin in
mario pohl gibt es nichts mehr nur
ruinen stellen sie sich vor genua wäre
komplett abgebrannt standing ovations
für selensky der am morgen erneut betont
hatte dass die ukraine nicht mehr darauf
besteht nato mitglied zu werden das
reicht den kreml aber nicht ein treffen
der präsidenten lehnt moskau weiter ab
die verhandlungen stocken die kämpfe
gehen weiter nikolov im süden der
ukraine liegt unweit der strategisch
wichtigen stadt odessa beide melden
luftangriffe in diesem krankenhaus in
nikolajew stehen die betten für die
patienten jetzt im keller hier werden
viele verletzte kinder behandelt
ich bitte die mütter russlands zu
protestieren damit unsere kinder am
leben bleiben
wir können putin das blutvergießen
niemals verzeihen sagt diese mutter
unter tränen
auch die zweitgrößte stadt aktiv im
osten der ukraine ist weiter schwer
umkämpft am mittag veröffentlicht das
russische verteidigungsministerium diese
aufnahmen russische einheiten auf dem
weg nach haccp die bilder sollen zeigen
dass der nachschub funktioniert die
ukrainische seite meldet dagegen immer
wieder dass den russischen panzern der
sprit ausgeht
und im westen der ukraine in venezia ist
unsere reporterin katrin eigendorf
kadetten die ukrainische regierung gibt
sicher hoffnungsvoll den russischen
angriffen weiter standhalten zu können
wie schätzen sie die kriegslage derzeit
ein
wir erleben jetzt ein moment wo für
wladimir putin klar wird dass er diesen
krieg nicht schnell gewinnen kann sein
ursprünglicher plan war ja in einer art
blitzkrieg hier die regierung zu
entmachten und eine russische
marionettenregierung zu implantieren das
funktioniert nicht mit diesem
erheblichen widerstand der ukrainischen
bevölkerung und auch mit den großen
erfolgen der ukrainischen militärs hat
der russische präsident nicht gerechnet
darauf waren vor allem seine
bodentruppen nicht eingerichtet und wir
leben jetzt hier eine situation dass im
prinzip nur um den preis der wirklich
totalen zerstörung weiter kreise weiter
landstriche der ukraine auch städte
dieser krieg hier zu gewinnen sein
könnte und das kann bleibt mir putin
eigentlich nicht wollen denn er müsste
sich dann hier auf einen jahrelangen
guerillakrieg einrichten aber ich sehe
trotzdem im moment noch nicht den
zeitpunkt gekommen wo putin wirklich
bereit scheint für verhandlungen aber er
wird sicherlich zunehmend unter druck
geraten was die militärische lage hier
am boden angeht einordnung von katrin
eigendorf in der ukraine vielen dank
dafür
und es gibt berichte über
kriegsverbrechen russischer truppen in
der ukraine
das zdf magazin frontal konnte jetzt
hintergründe recherchieren zu einem fall
der belegt ist und über den wir bereits
berichtet haben es geht um die
erschießung eines zivilisten und einer
zivilisten ein ehepaar durch russische
soldaten
ein bericht von an kinzel und christian
rohde
yuko maxime so wird schon seine frau
xenia der ukraine sie russen das paar
hat einen sohn 6 jahre alt
anfang märz bombardieren russische
streitkräfte in einen vorort von kiew
ganz in der nähe hatte sich die familie
in ihr wochenend hause zurück gezogen
erzählt uns der vater am telefon
alles war gut bis zum beschuss von
marcel rohr most l und trittin das war
hart und sie konnten laute explosion
hören
am 7 märz flüchtenden komax ihm seine
frau ihr kind und eine freundin in einem
konvoi aus der siedlung gegen 14 uhr
erreichen sie die schnellstraße e40
wenige kilometer westlich von kiew eine
ukrainische drohne filmt was passiert
form der silberne hyundai dahinter ein
blauer subaru die fahrer bemerkten eine
russische stellung auf dem panzer ein
erkennungszeichen der russischen armee
das v die aufnahmen zeigen auch das
mündungsfeuer eines schützen
durch die schüsse wurde die mutter
getötet weil sie mit ihrem körper das
kind geschützt hat
mein sohn stieg aus dem ort und hob
seine arme über den kopf er schrie
kinder nicht schießen
doch so wenn com axino ag wird von
kugeln getroffen bricht zusammen und
stirbt
der sechsjährige sohn gott und die
freundin der familie werden weggeführt
sie seien später freigelassen worden und
in sicherheit erzielt der großvater ob
die russischen soldaten oder gar
präsident putin zur rechenschaft gezogen
werden scheint heute mehr als fraglich
und weitere hintergründe und details zu
diesem vorfall können sie in frontal
sehen ab 21 uhr welche gründe gibt putin
offiziell für seinen krieg gegen die
ukraine an in einem faktencheck
untersuchen wir seine argumentation dass
alles in unserer zdf heute
in russland wurde der bekannteste
oppositionelle des landes alexej nawalny
heute von einem gericht zu weiteren neun
jahren haft verurteilt
die bundesregierung spricht von einem
akt der willkür
die vorsitzende des
menschenrechtsausschusses im bundestag
renate alt von der fdp nannte das urteil
zitat einen weiteren schritt
das russische regime in richtung einer
totalitären diktatur macht über die lage
der opposition und den feiner wein
christian senn
alexej nawalny umschwirrt von
sicherheitskräften das entlockt ihm nur
noch ein müdes gähnen über fünf stunden
dauert die urteilsverkündung im
straflager in dem er schon seit mehr als
einem jahr sitzt in dem neuen viel
kritisierten prozess jetzt kommen
weitere neun jahre haft unter strengen
bedingungen dazu wegen angeblicher
veruntreuung von geldern und wegen
beleidigung einer richterin
es ist keine überraschung dass putin
alexej gerne so lange im gefängnis
sitzen lassen will wie an der macht ist
wir sind uns absolut sicher dass das
sein direkter befehl ist alexej zu
inhaftieren
rückblick im august 20 20 überlebt
navalny in sibirien nur knapp einen ovid
schock vergiftung in deutschland erholt
sich der 45 jährige von dem anschlag und
fliegt im januar 20 21 nach russland
zurück noch am flughafen in moskau wird
er festgenommen und später verurteilt
russlands bekanntester oppositioneller
wurde aus dem weg geräumt und mit ihm
fast alle kreml gegner
wenn wir uns an die situation im jahr
2019 erinnern da war die infrastruktur
der opposition stark das netzwerk von
navalny war mächtig wir sehen dass der
niedergang der opposition im jahr 20 21
und der beginn des krieges eng
miteinander verbunden sind
eine gefährliche zeit für
regierungsgegner journalisten und auch
anwälte nach dem urteil heute wurden
auch navis verteidiger vor dem
straflager für kurze zeit festgenommen
kommen wir zu corona in deutschland
steigen die infektionszahlen nach wie
vor das robert koch institut
registrierte binnen eines tages
222.000 80 neue fälle das sind
23.000 192 mehr als vergangenen dienstag
264 menschen starben im zusammenhang mit
kurven 19 innerhalb eines tages die
sieben tage ins events ist weiter
gestiegen auf 1.700 33,4
auch bundespräsident frank walter
steinmeier und seine frau elke
büdenbender haben sich mit dem corona
virus infiziert die symptome seien mild
teilte eine sprecherin am dienstag in
berlin mit der bundespräsident und seine
frau hätten sich umgehend in häusliche
isolation begeben
die anhaltend hohen fallzahlen bereiten
den krankenhäusern wachsendes sorgen zum
einen sind immer mehr pflegekräfte und
ärzte und ärzte betroffen zum anderen
müssen immer mehr corona infizierte
versorgt werden ein lichtblick die lage
auf den intensivstationen bleibt stabil
aus hannover an den start
bloß keine neue krankmeldung hoffen und
bangen jetzt immer dabei wenn jens
albrecht unterwegs ist in seiner klinik
vincenz-krankenhaus hannover immer mehr
arbeit immer weniger arbeitskräfte immer
mehr ärzte pfleger und krankenschwestern
sitzen zu hause mit corona wie merkel
den krankenstand in allen bereichen des
krankenhauses das führt dazu dass
bestimmte betten zum teil nicht belegt
werden kann das führt im op dazu dass
auch bestimmte op patienten abgesagt
werden müssen
massive omikron personalausfälle ganze
wochen ohne geplante operationen etwa 75
prozent aller krankenhäuser in
deutschland können derzeit nicht mehr
alle leistungen wie gewohnt anbieten die
personalausfälle betreffen die
krankenhäuser flächendeckend über alle
stationen hinweg sie treffen aber
zusammen mit einer maximalen profit
belegung das heißt wir haben so viele
corona patientinnen und patienten
infektions patienten auf der
normalstation wie wir noch nie hatten
etwa 24.000 sind es aktuell bundesweit
immer öfter wird bei patienten erst im
krankenhaus entdeckt dass sie auch
corona jeder einzelne bedeutet
mehrarbeit mehr schutzmaßnahmen mehr
pandemie stress der sich ein stück
verlagert hat von den intensiv hinzu die
normalstation
wir haben in der tat eine nicht
unerhebliche zahl von patienten auf der
normalstation die aber durchaus auch
krankheits probleme haben also es ist
nicht nur der viel besagte schnupfen die
virus krise die sich verändert auch und
gerade in den krankenhäusern die aber
eben spürbar alles andere als vorbei ist
krisen sind teuer die kosten dafür aber
auch für neue investitionen sind heute
im bundestag präsentiert worden der
erste etatentwurf von
bundesfinanzminister lindner der
haushalt fürs laufende jahr hat einen
umfang von 400
57,6 milliarden euro die neuverschuldung
beträgt 99 7 milliarden allerdings
kommen nochmal 100 milliarden euro für
die bundeswehr dazu und ebenfalls noch
nicht berechnet weitere milliarden für
die folgen des krieges deshalb spricht
die opposition von einem haushalts
rätsel patrizier wiedemeier
so hatte christian lindner sich seinen
ersten haushaltsentwurf sicherlich nicht
vorgestellt ein haushalt mit einer
rekordverschuldung bedingt durch die
korona pandemie und den ukraine krieg
dafür gebe es aber keine
steuererhöhungen
die ampel verspricht zu konsolidieren
und zu investieren
wir gehen bei der transformation zur
wettbewerbsfähigen klimaneutral und
digitalen volkswirtschaft verlangen wir
steigern die investitionen insbesondere
im verkehrsbereich dort vor allem für
die schiene wir stärken sozialen
zusammenhalt durch ausgaben für bildung
und familie die stabilisierung des
arbeitsmarkt über 200 milliarden euro
für klimaschutz und transformation wird
es in den kommenden fünf jahren geben
und ein erstes umfangreiches entlastungs
paket von mehr als 16 milliarden euro
darin enthalten allein für dieses jahr
der einstieg in die kindergrundsicherung
die schuldenbremse werde ab 2023 wieder
eingehalten verspricht lindner in diesem
jahr jedoch wird es zusätzliche schulden
geben für die union ist klar sie will
dem sondervermögen von 100 milliarden
nur zustimmen wenn das geld
ausschließlich für die bundeswehr
genutzt wird insgesamt heftige kritik
der opposition
ihre bisherige bilanz heißt einen
verfassungswidrigen haushalt vorlegen
heute einen unvollständigen haushalt
nachliefern und eine grundgesetzänderung
an kündigt mit der rekordschulden in
deutschland gemacht werden hinzu kommen
explodierende strompreise
klimakrise wohnungsnot und wachsende
altersarmut und auf all diese probleme
gibt die bundesregierung mit diesem
haushalt keine antwort noch diese woche
soll es weitere entlastungen für die
bürger geben dieser haushaltsentwurf
dürfte keine lange halbwertzeit haben
und jetzt gute nachrichten für die rund
21 millionen rentnerinnen und rentner in
deutschland
ab juli werden ihre bezüge kräftig
steigen im westen um 5,35 prozent und im
osten sogar um 6,12 prozent
damit fällt der anstieg deutlich höher
aus als gedacht als grund nannte das
arbeitsministerium gestiegene einnahmen
der rentenkassen ausgelöst durch die
deutliche wirtschaftliche erholung trotz
der andauernden an dem
nach brandenburg zur eröffnung eines
mega projekts die erste tesla fabrik in
europa wurde der rekordzeit von nur zwei
jahren errichtet das unternehmen baute
in grünheide zunächst auf eigenes risiko
wichtige genehmigungen fehlten damals
noch das milliarden projekt ist die
größte industrieansiedlungen aus
deutschland seite wende
umweltschützerin und schützer
kritisieren den bau befürchten
schädliche folgen unter anderem für die
wasserversorgung heute nun der
offizielle produktionsstart einschätzung
bei
partylaune heute beim tesla start in
grünheide bei berlin
konzern chef elon musk ist angereist und
die ersten fahrzeuge an ihre käufer zu
übergeben
3000 arbeitskräfte sind hier derzeit
beschäftigt bis zu 12.000 sollen es
werden hoffnungen auf einen industrie
aufschwung in ostdeutschland jetzt
entsteht an dieser stelle im osten
deutschlands in brandenburg eine fabrik
mit einem international tätigen
unternehmen im rücken dass
elektrofahrzeuge ausschließlich
produziert ein gutes zeichen dafür dass
die deutsche einheit in dieser weise
richtig funktioniert für deutschland
entschied sich tesla weil das
unternehmen hier einen vorreiter für e
mobilität sieht eine vision die der
bundeswirtschaftsminister unterstützt
freude auch über die schnelle umsetzung
des projekts diese kurze zeit des
fabrikbau es kann natürlich auch ein
bisschen mal maßgabe sein für tesla
tempo auch in anderen bereichen ich
arbeite daran
begleitet wird die eröffnung aber auch
von protesten vor allem umweltbedenken
wogen bis zuletzt schwer brandenburg
leidet unter wasserknappheit tesla
könnte das verschärfen fürchten auch
anwohner
man hofft natürlich dass nicht so viele
schwierigkeiten gibt mit wasser und
natur und aber ansonsten wird es
arbeitsplatz arbeitsplätze geschaffen
werden können ja nicht verkehrt sein
ziel ist es hier bis zu 500.000 autos im
jahr zu bauen noch aber hinkt die
infrastruktur hinterher eine mammut
aufgabe der sich die behörden jetzt
stellen müssen
die ard wird vorerst die einzige
bundestagsfraktion ohne stellvertreter
im präsidium bleiben die partei
scheiterte mit dem versuch den posten
vor dem bundesverfassungsgericht zu
erstreiten die karlsruher richterinnen
und richter wiesen den antrag der
fraktion als offensichtlich unbegründet
zurück auch die klage eines einzelnen
fdp-abgeordneten blieb ohne erfolg
beleidigungen beschimpfungen
diffamierende behauptungen traurige
realität für viele abgeordnete vor allem
in den sozialen netzwerken jetzt gab es
eine razzia gegen mutmaßliche verfasser
und verfasserin von hass posts in 13
bundesländern durchsuchte die polizei
wohnungen und vernahm mehr als 100
verdächtige dabei ging es um
beleidigungen und diffamierungen im
zusammenhang mit der bundestagswahl
betroffen waren vor allem politikerinnen
quer durch alle großen parteien
viele flugreisende haben heute in
deutschland lange wartezeiten
verspätungen oder flugausfälle in kauf
nehmen müssen grund ist ein weiterer
warnstreik des sicherheitspersonals wie
hier in frankfurt am main lebten
kontrolleuren kontrolleure an insgesamt
neun flughäfen die arbeit nieder die
gewerkschaft verdi fordert ein lohnplus
von mindestens einem euro die stunde
sowie regionale gehalts angleichungen am
donnerstag sollen die tarifgespräche in
die nächste runde jetzt
kommt ihr zur deutschen
fußball-nationalmannschaft norbert da
stehen ja gleich zwei länderspiele in
folge samstagabend in sinsheim gegen
israel zu sehen bei uns in zdf und dann
am dienstag in amsterdam gegen die
niederlande die ersten tests für das
team von hansi flick im wm jahr 2022
heute in frankfurt trainingsauftakt
erste runde im gerangel um die wm
kaderplätze acht monate hat das team um
bundestrainer hansi flick zeit um in den
test- und nations league spielen die
passende formation zu finden ist
natürlich ein anderes wm jahr
was eigentlich wunderbar unter dem
aspekt ist dass es immer sich steigert
um zum ende des jahres dann der
höhepunkt kommt mit julian weigel kehrt
ein alter bekannter zur
nationalmannschaft zurück genau fünf
jahre nach seinem letzten länderspiel
kapitän manuel neuer heute mit einer
klaren zielvorgabe und für mich
gibt es nur ein ziel sich
titel da dürfte sicher niemand einwände
haben
das spiel deutschland israel wird
bewirken ist teil der bundesweiten
solidaritätsaktionen des dfb und seiner
landesverbände bei allen fußballspielen
von profis und amateuren am kommenden
wochenende sollen spenden für die
ukraine gesammelt werden ja wir bleiben
beim thema ukraine sie floh vor dem
krieg aus ihrer heimat holte jetzt für
ihre heimat die goldmedaille im
hochsprung am wochenende in belgrad bei
der hallen-wm jaroslava matschig die
ukrainerin trainiert seit heute in
deutschland diese goldmedaille eine ganz
besondere die erst 20-jährige
hochspringerin hat der ukraine und
vielen menschen damit etwas hoffnung
geschenkt und mut gemacht in schlimmen
kriegstagen
ich habe hunderte nachrichten aus der
ukraine bekommen dieses gold war so gut
und wichtig endlich ein grund zum
lächeln und zum glücklichsein eine 60
stündige anreise mit dem auto bis nach
belgrad nicht trainiert die gedanken
ständig in der heimat und trotzdem der
sprung zu gold mit zwei metern und 2
jetzt trainiert sie in deutschland ein
sponsor aus herzogenaurach kümmert sich
will auch ihre familie nachholen die
geschichte der erst 20-jährigen jahres
hlawatschek eine von viel willenskraft
und stärke
am samstag ist nicht zu gast bei uns im
aktuellen sportstudio
und zum schluss haben wir noch diese
wunderschönen bilder ein paar kein see
und kirschblüten mehr braucht es nicht
um jeden frühling wieder die
einwohnerinnen und besucher von
washington zu verzücken
3000 bäume in voller blüte gerade für
urlauberinnen und urlauber ist der
perfekte moment dafür allerdings schwer
zu planen denn zwischen mitte märz und
mitte april könnte es jeden moment so
weit sein glück also für alle die in der
frühlings lotterie von washington auf
diese woche gesetzt haben
und von schönen bildern zum schönen
wetter sonnig ist es und bleibt es mehr
gleich von katja schäfer dazu um 21.45
dann das heute journal wird christian
sievers schönen abend noch
[Musik]
guten abend auch in dieser nacht wird es
wieder sehr kalt die temperaturen sinken
auf plus fünf bis minus fünf grad meist
ist der himmel klar nur ganz selten kann
sich mir etwas nebel oder dunst bilden
der wind kommt aus östlichen richtungen
und dreht morgen über tag auf nordost
das hat an der ostseeküste zur folge
dass dort die temperaturen nur auf elf
grad steigen wenn das wasser ist nur
fünf grad kalt sonst wird es aber sehr
mild mit bis zu 20 grad am niederrhein
und so ähnlich geht es dann auch in den
nächsten tagen weiter höchstens in
norddeutschland sind die wolken einmal
etwas dichter sonst bleibt es aber sehr
freundlich bei uns guten abend